new year new oopsies I'm poppy Gloria
and this is who knows we have so many
oopsies already guys I cannot believe it
ninja tyranny Lucy rice come did an
oopsie jake paul dierden oopsie and
soldier boy did and oopsie it's open see
time if you guys haven't seen the ninja
clip an oh boy are you in for a treat
it's so beautiful I love it so much
so apparently ninja was at the ball drop
in New York City that they do every year
apparently I never seen it cuz I don't
live in America but wait I do actually
but ninja took part of it this year and
I love me some good cringe and this is
just what I want I freed up this stuff
let's watch if you guys have all floss
before go simple I mean like with your
teeth 3 I mean you're just going in out
in out and it's just it that's it so
we're gonna try to get a million people
right now to dance in Times Square a
million people on in New York City are
gonna floss finally finally oh I'm so
excited are you guys ready are you guys
ready to floss show us what you got so
much what you got let's get some floss
music on we're getting ready so wet so
wet it's so awesome should we count down
we're gonna get some tunes off really
ready every three two one
yeah
ba-baby we got no other flushing oh my
god the wrong flossing
[Music]
killing ninja no one is moving the pain
can you imagine walking up there you
expect a million the crowd of millions
to be flossing in unison everyone just
picked up this dance to move out of
nowhere and they just oh no good [ __ ]
pick anyone that knew how to do the
dance what is that
wait did he just say he's gonna hit his
wife for us replay that clip please why
are not mainstream media talking about
this this just confirmed ninja
wife-beater is this why he doesn't play
with women we reached out to ninja for a
response now I know I'm not supposed to
have my own opinion but I cannot relate
to this whatsoever I have personally not
have any experience of being on stage
and not having that connection with the
audience not nothing never happened
I'll have you know that that was late
okay
I know buzz cringy as this clip was I
mean what do you expect you're not gonna
get a couple bunch of New Yorkers in the
middle of the rain do getting to Fort
ninth dances like who thought that was a
good idea but this is not all that
controversy if you want to call it that
it's really not but twitch was heavily
pushing people to watch this on their
website to watch this live stream watch
a ninja live they promoted it on the
very top of all all their banners or
whatever and they even had ads on other
people's live streams oh is that so it's
like oh I click on this person but then
an ad shows up of hey you should watch a
ninja you don't want to watch this guy
you want to watch ninja do the flossing
in front of the thousands of people and
a lot of people had a problem with this
especially twitch streamers doctor
disrespects saying dear twitch get these
ugly looking New Year's Eve ad rolls off
my page don't ever do it again either
ever I mean I'd probably be pretty
annoyed of that as well as content
creators ironically have no say in what
ads show up on our videos if another
youtuber paid ads or had ads to show up
before my videos going hey subscribe to
me I'd be annoyed by it I get it guys I
get the struggle most likely ninja had
nothing to do with that anyway this is a
problem when you are lending your brand
for sponsorships or whatever this was
you are going to get for a lot of stuff
because you don't control it even though
you personally wouldn't do it that way
does that make sense
it's the reason why I me personally I I
don't accept a lot of brand deals if I
don't know exactly what's gonna happen
with it and a lot of times it is beyond
your control as well I think it's funny
though cuz a lot of times you get these
brand news that sound cool okay you're
gonna livestream on Times Square during
New Year's Eve that's a huge opportunity
there's gonna be millions of viewers
there live or whatever and you'll get
paid a ton of money sounds great right
and then reality hits and it's like this
next oopsie
Soulja Boy's emulator console meets
their inevitable and no not so to Boise
game console we report about this on the
last few news Soulja Boy had his own
video game console which was basically
just an overpriced version of another
already available console that basically
just emulates old Nintendo games Wow
three thousand Nintendo games sounds
like a great idea Soulja Boy is selling
a console that's basically an overpriced
emulator well it turns out now if you go
to Soulja Boy's website it's nowhere to
be found where is it why is the soldier
game I wanna buy a well it turns out the
Soulja Boy game console is gone Soulja
Boy's a response to this was I had to
boss up I didn't have a choice you had
to boss down you boss the Frankie down
Soulja Boy don't try to up play yourself
I love the replies to this tweet by the
way yeah what happened to his dream
Soulja Boy is sister this is a guy with
a dream I had a dream last night that I
got married to a [ __ ] SM edge s MH
they focus on your dreams create
something big make history
thank your soldier boy for inspiring
messages I don't understand why
everyone's hating on a soldier boy he's
been so humbled throughout all of this
Nintendo ain't gonna do [ __ ]
the games were licensed to us why y'all
want to see a man fail so bad S&H huh
can I just marry a [ __ ] SM Paige for
anyone that thing's Nintendo is going to
sue me you're right nothing's gonna
happen
everything is legit my console isn't
going anywhere
trust me oh I trust Soulja Boy I always
lend my trust to this man to anyone that
thinks Nintendo's after me you're wrong
Media Takeout post that fake story they
haven't taken any legal action because
he can't that's right they can't that's
why it's still available to buy on his
website now everyone noticed that your
riddles did soldier boy congratulations
congratulations who would have thought
and attend you though would actually
crack down on me so debo who said that
day his console sold five million units
I sincerely doubt it and if even if you
did you're gonna have to pay all that
money back aren't you Soulja Boy
oopsie-doopsie and probably more you'll
probably get fined oh no because you
gloated so much about this
oopsie-doopsie oopsie-doopsie next oopsy
Jake Paul and Raskin what did they do
now okay alright okay well they promoted
a brand called mystery brand which is it
looks identical to one of those csgo
gambling sites where you gamble for
skins I mean look look at look at the
difference I mean they look practically
identical it's similar to any gambling
sites but instead of gambling for skins
you're gambling for actual brand
products like shoes and phones and bags
and cards you can even win cars how
about that it seemed like a bad idea to
promote these kind of websites
especially considering after the csgo
lotto scandal that happened a few years
ago where T Martin and syndicate was
calling basically owning the web site
and cheating their way to victory faking
reactions going wow I'm winning so much
so now we have Jay Paul promoting this
[Applause]
I spent five thousand on mystery boxes
and you won't believe what I got an
iPhone an iPhone and then rice come as
well promoted this so you want a $10,000
handbag what are the odds
something smells a bit fishy about this
they both won considerable amount of
items just from unboxing just a few at
least what they showed there's a couple
things wrong with this but I'll start
with the most obvious one rice come and
Jake Paul have considerably young fans
and promoting a gambling website in
general just seems like a bad idea for
these people to do now obviously they
don't care and if they don't I mean what
can you do
I personally don't like this argument
cuz I get it a lot myself people go oh
or you make a pretty inappropriate jokes
but you have kids watching you well it's
not my responsibility who watches my
channel I think though there is a
problem with Jake who basically admits
that he knows kids are watching him who
is your audience who do you make your
videos for if my audiences is definitely
younger I'd say it's like eight years
old - like 16 years old and so that's
where I try to like cater the content
hated the content by promoting gambling
okay it's not like it's a big expose
that these people aren't the most
morally ethical or whatever but the
second problem with this is that smaller
youtubers have already promoted these
websites and they've been called out for
it this is how their promotion looks
like oh baby is right oh I gotta do the
cut proper you know
shut the hell up shut shut up No
is this is this a joke this is supposed
to be legit
what do that can't be real
that can't be real it's not it's not
real
hey here's what it actually looks like
when you're unbox basically 40 boxes
nothing over 50 15 bucks now obviously
this is not proof that there's foul play
there's nothing concrete it's just
saying well it seems like they're
winning more than it actually is
now the third issue with this is
shipping on all these sponsored videos
they kind of make it seem like it just
takes two days or a couple days to get
your items all right guys it's been two
to three days I don't even know I think
it's been around two days and guess what
we got some stuff but online it says
people are waiting over 65 days and no
progress on their items people are
saying that they're not even giving a
proper tracking number for it given the
benefit of the doubt these mashed ups
can happen obviously shipping gets is a
lot of times out of the control of the
supplier but considering how you
advertise it making it so easy to get
the items it's kind of false advertising
now the final juiciest bit in my opinion
is that on the website it says that you
can win some pretty crazy stuff just pay
$4 and you can win a strong no me i
watch that's crazy expensive a
Lamborghini a Bentley another
Lamborghini another Mercedes a Range
Rover Bob above all these super
expensive items obviously so someone on
Twitter called crypto Delta found out
that here's the odds that they display
that is the chance of you winning one of
these items hey look there's the there's
a handbag that rice gum 1 0.16 percent
wow it must be a really lucky guy and if
you look at the most expensive items a
Lamborghini for 0.15 percent that's sort
of a reasonable percentage considering
you're only paying $15 right it doesn't
really make any sense it would still be
that sort of a high chance
I know it's high on quotation mark for
you to win one of these in crazy
expensive items you can still have a
decent chance of winning any of these
well basically this website has a
feature called create your own box
where you can basically make identical
boxes as anyone else so this person
decided to create the same box with the
exact same items with the exact same
odds and the price that they calculate
for this if you put in the same odds in
the same out and it should show up on
the same price I know it's a little
confusing but it basically should show
up that it costs 1499 dollars for this
box because it's the exact same boss but
as it turns out for this to be
profitable or for this to meet ends I
guess you could say
according if you create your own it
costs seven thousand five hundred and
eighty nine thousand dollars for this
box so basically if you were gambling
for the odds that they say they have you
should have to pay seven thousand per
box but in reality you're paying 1499
which means that these odds are bogus
they're not correct
basically proof that what they're
displaying is not attainable in the way
that they say it is so all the sudden
this idea that they are marketing
through youtubers that it's easier to
win something then it actually isn't
doesn't seem like that crazy of an of a
concept anymore suddenly that's not such
a crazy of a thing I'm gonna put my
tinfoil hat on for just a second here it
seems like the people that are sponsored
are genuinely surprised over winning
these items it seems like they're almost
skeptical in their reaction if you watch
[Music]
shut the hell up shut shut up No
is this is this a joke this is supposed
to be legit I don't know for sure like I
have to wait till this comes in because
this doesn't look the exact same but
this says nike air off-white vapour max
black
great I like how he's doing a
sponsorship with his company and he's
still he's not even sure if it's legit
he's like I don't know if this is legit
what do that can't be real
that can't be real my theory is that
they create an account and they give
some better odds to that account that's
obviously just a theory I have no idea
if that's true or not that's just what
my guess would be they give they say hey
what's your account or it will give you
an account or something like that
and give you improved odds while you do
that is my guess I have no idea if it's
true or not
but I wouldn't be surprised if that was
the case let's just put it that way
keemstar said himself but he was upper
offered a hundred thousand to do a
promotion for this website and I I can
confirm i've been reached out by similar
websites and they they pay an insane
amount of money that's crazy amount of
money in these things so obviously
they're very profitable it's this kind
of messed up to see youtubers still
promoting these things there's so many
youtubers it's hard to know exactly the
ins and out workings of every brand you
work with but seeing big youtubers
promote something like this that's
clearly been known to be sketchy it's
it's kind of messed up okay so that was
it for puny hope you guys enjoyed this
episode smash like if you did a great
way to support the show is to buy some
merch everybody everyone that buys emerg
have a 0.16 percent chance of winning a
Lamborghini so make sure you go on and
take this offer right freaking now
that's it for me for now I'm Gloria
poppy and doopsy juicy bye you want
pyramids
we got them oh you're into castles huh
we got you covered baby you want some
bets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit